hey hi hello welcome to the book history
colloquium at Columbia I'm Carly Nielsen
I'm the curator of literature here in
the Columbia Rare Book and Manuscript
library I'm very excited to see you all
here tonight our panelists are in fact
here it's just in the audience and will
be coming up one by one because all of
them have slide presentations and they
want to see each other's slides and
before we get into tonight's panel I
wanted to announce a few upcoming Tut's
in the book history colloquium if you
are here because you're very interested
in handmade book you might want to come
in two weeks for Janice radaway
presentation girls jeans and thereafter
lives on the significance of multiple
multiple networks and itineraries of
dissent the talk is gonna be preceded by
a tour of the Barnard Dean library just
across pride Broadway at 5 p.m. and
professor Broadway's current project
involves interviewing a number of New
York City zine creators and singing
librarians many of whom will be here for
that presentation so it should be a
particularly interesting question and
answer session November is a good month
for early modernists on Monday November
4th
Randall McLeod will present on the birth
of italics and on Thursday November 14th
William Sherman is leading a seminars
last talk on the readers eye between
annotation and illustration and then
last a very late in the semester on
Wednesday December 11th we will have a
panel on personalities and post-war
publishing with Lauren glass born Boras
touchpad and J Kurtzman speaking about
respectively Barney russet of grave
breasts
Roger stress at Farrar Straus duro and
Samuel draft creator of so many imprints
that I can't even mention them and if
this all sounds intriguing but you
didn't retain any of the details feel
free to add yourself to our mailing list
which is over there on the cadenza or
check out the website ok and now for
tonight's panel I'm going to introduce
all of the panelists upfront and then
they'll come up to you to give a
presentation then we'll have a Q&A at
the end and then the reception extra
so first up will be Rachel fader Rachel
fader is a Mellon postdoctoral fellow in
the Department of English at Rutgers
University her current research focuses
on nineteenth-century
commonplace books book history and
experimental poetics and really seems to
range from the 18th century to the 21st
century it starts to be really exciting
um Alan Gruber Garvey's most recent book
writing with scissors American
scrapbooks from the Civil War to the
Harlem Renaissance came out from Oxford
University Press earlier this year she
is also the author of the adman in the
parlor magazines and the gendering of
consumer culture which came out from
Oxford University Press in 1996 which
was winner of a sharp prize for best
book she is the professor of English at
New Jersey City University last up will
be Karen Sanchez Epler he was the elf
danton Williams 1941 professor of
American Studies and English at Amherst
College and the author of touching
Liberty abolition feminism and the
politics of the body which came out from
the University of California Press in
1993 and dependent States the child's
part in 19th century American culture
which came out from the University of
Chicago Press in 2005 she's currently
working on two book projects the on the
unpublished republic mein uske cultures
of the mid 19th century United States
and the archives of childhood personal
and historical pasts please join me in
welcoming tonight's panel hi and Rachel
my talk this evening is called marginal
experiments my remarks today are drawn
from an ongoing project that identifies
an alternate history of poetic
experiment grounded in 18th and 19th
century women's daily writing as text
objects that imitate public forms while
serving private functions the homemade
and handwritten books I study operate a
sites of intertextual and generic
invention
additionally books of women's daily
writing from the 18th and 19th centuries
anticipate leader experimental poetry
that negotiates negotiates the
overlapping public and private spheres
represented by
it's literal and theoretical materiality
so for example we can think of the late
modernist meograph revolution or of the
founding precepts of language poetry as
following from these traditions by
reconnecting modern and contemporary
poetry to an under theorized archive of
18th and 19th century women's writing I
am working to reveal a tradition of
literary invention focused on the
materiality of text and language on the
cross
genre experience of archival reading and
on the aesthetics of textual and
literary historical marginality for the
purposes of this evenings panel I'll
start by saying a few words about a
contemporary writer whose work
epitomizes the material and marginal
experiments but I'm attempting to
historicize and then I'll use this long
literary circle framework to think about
one archival artifact with its textural
overlays reproductions of handwritten
papers and typographical plays susan
house poetic and critical work
participates in the poetics of the found
or archival text interpreted across the
schools of modern and contemporary
poetry from the bre college of high
modernism to twitter generated poems it
also cultivates what we might call a
commonplace aesthetic a historic system
gauge meant with textual and material
history and marine mclean called how a
Haunter of archives for whom manuscripts
and marginalia
and indexes are muses so i can do it oh
yes okay great so just to give you a
sense of how this aesthetic I'll sort of
move quickly through a couple of slides
this is a page from souls of the Labadie
tract and so and the two slides that
I'll give you are from different tags
that sort of negotiate textual history
and deal with archives then we can see
here this aesthetic of the fragment
right so we have something new that's
been written but it's also been erased
it's been cut it's been pasted right
it's produced in such a way that we're
aware of its materiality and we're aware
of the fact that we can never access it
right all sort of thematic over
that kyun to what the book is about and
then similarly this is an actual just
page manuscript page that's reproduced
as part of pierce-arrow
right so this is just to give you a
quick sense of how how uses at the
archive in her experimental sort of
hybrid poetic and critical project and
of course we can think of her best-known
work by Emily Dickinson right it's very
much I'm in this game and and it's a
work that asked to quote from Amelie
Dickinson what is the communal vision of
poetry if you are curved odd indefinite
irregular feminine so this archival
project also has a feminist right a
feminist edge to it okay so before I
move from this very quick snapshot of
Susan housework to a discussion of an
archival artifact the collection of
poems that Dorothy Wordsworth calls
composed consolations and that I call
the commonplace chapbook I should
clarify that I've opened with Susan Howe
rather than with another 20th or 21st
century poet interested in margins and
materials and there are very very money
for two reasons the first is that I
think that how makes explicit the ways
in which language poetry athletes not
only as a sort of poetic counterweight
to deconstruction but also as a mode of
engagement with the 19th century and
this is an overlooked aspect I think the
language poetry is intervention into the
poetic to be stability modernist period
right debates about south hood and do
things about how to respond to poetic
history in the second reason I've
invoked L has to do with my
understanding of Dorothy Wordsworth as a
19th century woman writer who knows that
she is literally and figuratively
writing in the margins of a literary
history that she is helping to construct
so there's a self-awareness there let's
resonant okay so with this in mind I'll
turn to Wordsworth's commonplace book
and more specifically to a section of
that book that stands apart in words
it's commonplace book palms are penciled
and margins own and please ding
cocky doubt worked and reworked over
pages and years right so that's just one
page and you can see the poetry in the
margins at one point in the commonplace
book we find ourselves in a poetry
collection or a selection of poems
clustered together following a title
page that reads sickbed consolations
compose during the spring of the year
1832 right so that's where what I'm
calling to come and please chat books
start that is a close-up of the title
page and I'll just pause here since part
of what I'm talking about today is
artifice and the way that these look
like daily texts but they're in fact
artistic types right some of these poems
were not actually composed the mere 1832
right that's a sort of false story of
the poem in the collection following the
pebble caved the collection that I'm
calling a commonplace Chapa
the poems lines and lines intended for
anything album to door Wordsworth lines
intended for Edith studies album
floating on the hawk head and incident
in the schemes of nature and thoughts on
a sickbed are written relatively neatly
and in matching ink sharing not only
topics but also leaves the paper
gathered together in a working community
of text the consolations occur both in
the commonplace book and separate from
both in a collection and as discreet
label text the overall aesthetic of the
chat book is one of working papers
brought to bear on one another in an
artistic project a collection of poems
that not only is so made but also means
insofar as it is coming an assortment of
domestic reflections or sickbed
consolations and this is sort of inside
the chat book reading the chat book
involves moving from poem to poem
sometimes lifting an insert or tilting
the commonplace book at a different
angle handling the material deciding
what to read and have let's linger for a
moment with questions of genre
Wordsworth calls the verse selections
that make up the commonplace trap book
consolations the poems work as consul
nations by way of their religious
allegories naturalistic metaphors
dedications and II vocations they also
work as consolations by coming together
to form a textual environment that the
reader can inhabit brought together in a
thematic collection and inscribed within
the daily communal space of the
commonplace book these poems invite the
reader to enter an inner circle of the
personal archives to read within
multiple generic contexts at once
the reader is consoled not only by the
post content but also by the film's
textual context which includes the
reader in a live community of text and
if I had world enough and time we could
go through the chat book poem by poem
and see how the text ask and answer
questions and call out to each other
across margins and within the echo
chamber of their shared pages it's a
deeply dialogic work kind of like a
mixtape on the theme of consolation
write the poems are all really in
conversation with each other and this
set of pages in this book within a book
in addition to words forest genre label
consolations I'm using the term
commonplace chat book in order to
express my understanding of this
collection of poems and of course my
training and historical products leads
me to question my use of the term poems
when in fact I'm referring to a
collection of text that was worth labels
as consolations and I'll keep using the
word Tom's for the sake of clarity but
we should note that Dorothy Wordsworth
may not have thought about all of these
poems in that way right there within a
book of daily reading and some of them
are titled write lines intended for and
then directed and another book of
women's daily writing so there's also
something else going on here
by Chapa I mean that this collection of
texts is not only ephemeral but also
book historical it imitates the book
it's contained in a book and it imagines
both present and future readerships and
I'll say more about this in a moment by
commonplace I mean that the collection
not only occurs within the pages of
Wordsworth commonplace book but also
that it seems to be in
tended for someone meant to serve some
kind of social function in here I'm
picking up on recent critical work most
notably Meredith Michaels argument that
although common placing is performed by
individuals it is anti individualistic
insofar that highlights the means by
which subject understood to be plural
and iterable are produced suggesting
that therefore commonplace books provide
a storehouse of text through which
experience can be managed and understood
as well as Virginia Jackson's cleanly we
can understand Emily Dickinson's
manuscript and in a way I'm thinking
about Dorothy Wordsworth as sort of a
British like that a lot of the new ways
that we've thought about Emily Dickinson
we can also think about Dorothy
Wordsworth although I'm situating her
and they work within a number of known
and unknown 18th and 19th country figure
okay but Virginia Jackson argues that we
can understand Emily Dickinson's worth
manuscripts differently when we return
them to their social circumstances and
here's where all invoked Susan Howe
because I think the sociable
circumstances that define Wordsworth
daily writing extend beyond the current
residents of dove cottage or Riedel
Mount or even any particular moment in
literary history here as in the grasmere
journals
Dorothy Wordsworth is writing to the
archive she's writing in the margins of
literary history this is a practice that
sometimes involves the invention of new
genres and the creation of new
communities of text that invoke complex
audiences at once real and imagined and
in this way Dorothy Wordsworth
commonplace chalk book not only invented
genre a series of constellations in a
shared book of daily writing some
intended or directed for yet other books
of daily writing all labeled with a year
of composition that is as I mentioned in
some visas inaccurate but also invents a
scene of encounter a possibility of
reading at once scripted and unlikely
real and impossible at once bound by
daily life and extending beyond that
daily life into the margins of literary
history I'll pause here to say a few
words about one of the poems or
constellations in the
that book okay so this is floating
island at hawks head and incident in the
screams of nature and I'll read you
Susan lemons transcription because it's
not super legible harmonious powers with
nature work on sky earth River lakyn see
sunshine and storm whirlwind and breeze
all in one duteous task agree once did I
see a slip of Earth by throbbing waves
long undermined loose from its hold how
no one knew
but all might see it float obedient to
the wind might seen it from the verdant
shore discovered float upon the lake
float with its crust of trees adorned on
which the warbling birds their pastime
teeth food shelter safety there they
find their berries right then flower its
bloom their insects leave live their
lives and die the peopled world it is in
size a tiny room and thus through many
seasons space this little island may
survive but nature though we mark her
not will take away may cease to give
perchance when you are wandering forth
upon some vacant sunny day without an
object hope or fear whither your eyes
may turn the Isle is passed away buried
beneath the glittering link it's please
no longer to be found yet the lost
fragments shall remain to fertilize some
other crack the poem is published in
Dorothy Wordsworth lifetime in a format
that changes and distorts it in
fascinating ways that I would love to
discuss with you during the question and
answer session and that may be one of
the reasons that the poem has survived
as one of Wordsworth best-known poems
floating island has been read several
different ways by literary critics
Kenneth traveli has considered the
possibility that the pony anticipates
some of today's ecology awareness Lily
Maria Crisafulli has looked at the poems
naturalistic symbolism and Jill Annan
has considered how the poem might
express a metaphor for subjectivity and
writing and
I personally elsewhere write my reading
is that this is the poem where Dorothy
Wordsworth responds to William
Wordsworth's interpretation of Locke's
definition of identity in terms of
infinity and maybe we should save that
for the Q&A as well that I see this as a
sort of philosophical intervention into
a discourse about what the natural world
can tell us about ourselves and how
those principles are logical and
mathematical okay but all of those all
of those readings aside for our present
purposes we can also read this poem as a
statement of poetics something like
Dorothy words for its own interpretation
of the romantic fragment poem reimagined
not as the work that purports to be
fragmentary but rather as a text that
promises to be a fragment in the future
the commonplace chapbook like the island
is seen and understood in the present
right it's written for a literary
community that's also a domestic
community where people are sick and
there's a bug that's going around and
they need constellations but it is also
in addition to operating within that
literary and domestic community that
shares homemade and handwritten text the
commonplace chat book by Framing itself
as a new kind of book a commonplace
collection of consolations conjures a
moment of marginal archival encounter
Brayton this is the sort of experience
of reading in the archives that Susan
Howe describes as follows that sense of
the spurned book the hidden one is
intuitive it's a sense of
self-identification and Trust that
widens to delight discovering accidental
originals or feeling that you're pulling
something back you're rescuing or
bringing them into the light you could
call it civil Eve disobedience telepathy
if you if you wanted to write when we
attend to the reason which
nineteenth-century books of daily
reading invent new genres we also
recognize the ways in which these genres
imply both immediate and distant
readerships anticipating the modern
aesthetics of the found texts so to say
it plain as a devoted
Eclair in the margins of romantic
literary history Dora Wordsworth Creed's
books of daily writing that tell the
story of her experience of baladora
history in some of these books like
those careful and artful volumes that
make up the grasmere journals which also
by the way have lies on that and write
days got switched around if you look at
the manuscript so a sunny day comes
after a rainy day instead of a rainy day
right coming after a sunny day they're
very artfully crafted um so some of
these books like the grasmere journals
activate established genre and then some
of these books like the hidden book to
take house term that is the commonplace
chapbook perform intertextual and
generic experiments and these are
experiments that we have overlooked and
their experiments crucial to
understanding the experimental poetry of
our own historical moment so I'll
conclude by sharing a few thoughts about
teaching Dorothy Wordsworth reading the
commonplace chat book generates one
answer to the question of what is lost
or rather what has been lost in the
ongoing process of recovering Romantic
women's poetry from the archive and
introducing this poetry to the Canon
Wordsworth's writings present a problem
for these sorts of recovery efforts
because her works become denatured and D
materialize when removed from the
textual corpus but they and they're
implied leaders and habit when we
isolate Dorothy words words poetry or
what we think of as her poetry from its
material historical context we overlook
its experimental nature when you take
these poems out of the commonplace chat
book which and we can talk more about
floating island when it's actually
published right they read like elegies
they sort of succumb to the generic
constructions that we use to read an
18th century verse just as William
Wordsworth frames the lyrical ballads as
an experiment in cross-genre publication
so to do the various embedded frames of
Dorothy Wordsworth archives her poems
written and sewn and stuck within a
chapbook inscribed within a commonplace
book for example in act experiments in
materiality genre and
audience Dorothy orders other K survives
as a special case of radicalize
McDonough's and touch realized or
captured in overlapping forms and mode
words horse body of work written to
herself written for her friends and
family
occasionally revised her publication and
also directed somehow beyond these
tangibles to a future readership
produces a discursive field in which
archival genres mixed media and
attention to materiality activate poetic
experiments and invent new forms of
reading such forms and inventions draw
on and are revealed by in their material
context in history in other words to
understand Dorothy Wordsworth as an
experimental later we must attend to her
experimental archive at the same time
access to the archive is a privilege
that we can't easily share with our
students and this is where my literary
historical argument becomes pedagogical
when we understand 18th and 19th century
women writers as part of a long history
of marginal experiments we can see their
work more clearly as critics we can also
help our students experience what I'm
calling the archivists act right and
that's the kind of it but a commonplace
aesthetic that is part of what Susan
Howe is doing and it's part of what
happens when we as critics and
librarians and curators sort of go into
the archive right there's a there's an
aesthetics to that archive effect right
that has yet to be fully fully theorized
so in addition to teaching Dorothy
Wordsworth with attention to the text
material history we can also help our
student students put Wordsworth's work
into conversation with the writings of
modern and contemporary poets such as
laramie de coeur Linda Ginny and great
Armentrout and bhanu kapil all of whom
account for the theorized materiality of
language and the limitless poetic
potentials just thus employed I argue
that these and related product
experiments have important antecedents
not only in nineteenth-century
experimental poetry but also in daily
writing women's writing and writing
towards the archive
put another way the sorts of cross-genre
and textual material experiments
performed by Dorothea Wordsworth and her
poetry and daily writings signal an
alternate romantic inheritance all of
this is to suggest that when we theorize
the experience of archival reading we
open up new possibilities for
historicizing the experimental poetry of
our own historical moment via an
alternate genealogy of ideas we also
open up new possibilities for teaching
the history of women's writing that
illuminate the historical texts and
elucidate the experimental poetry of our
own historical moments attending to the
literal margins of the poetic Canon
reveals a history of poetic experiments
that manipulate their marginal status
and that activate generic innovation and
invention grounded in questions of
materiality attending to Dorothy
Wordsworth commonplace Chopra a homemade
book within a handwritten ebook a site
of generic and intertextual innovation
represents a first stop in
reconstructing this alternate literary
history that first step is to read daily
and private and women's writing as
experimental and Dorothy Wordsworth
commonplace chat book is a good place to
start
thank you hello and thank you Carla for
organizing this panel this is terrific
now I've been giving you a close I'm
gonna move to a much broader overview
now so you may have heard about the
doings of reality TV star Lauren Conrad
year or so ago who posted a crafts
project on YouTube where she that showed
her cutting up new new copies of books
of by Lemony Snicket the series of
unfortunate events amputating their
spines with an exacto knife and laying
out the severed backbones in orderly
rows and then attaching them to a box
with a glue gun she explains this is a
great way to display vintage books
slightly used books and then she notes
that she takes some of the leftover
pages and hangs them up on her walls so
Twitter Facebook the social media were
all over her about it and attacked her
in great quantity and even after her
staff took the video down off of YouTube
a bootleg copies circulated this one's
off of Paris Hilton's a Paris Hilton's
site as you can see and angry comments
about the destruction of books you know
some rain down through the blogs and
whatnot so she's called a book murderer
on some of them and it's it and it
probably didn't help that she ends the
whole thing with a kind of cheery share
with us what books you're reading now
suggesting that she actually had an
interest in the actual texts of books
but turning books into non books has a
very long history and it's sometimes
taking advantage of the prestigious
appearance of books on the shelf and
turning them into receptacles of various
less classy pursuits either the actual
craft of book destruction as we see it
here or in this candy is dandy but
liquor is picker pairing where the books
become hiding places so sometimes the
book itself is kept whole but the but in
a sense emptied of its contents you can
buy into the various websites where you
can buy books by the foot and so even if
you could read these books I mean even
though you can read these books they've
been turned into decor bestowing an aura
of wisdom and and solid old wealth
generally Megan Benton has written and
wonderfully about this I says Nicholson
Baker on the other hand you can also buy
Reader's Digest books by the foot and
there's a question then of exactly what
you're displaying but perhaps a thick
book has gravitas of its own so this
business of of annexing the prestige of
books of destroying books to reuse them
has a long history of inspire
revulsion and justification the tens of
thousands of 19th century scrapbook
makers whoo-hoo the tens of 19th century
readers who wanted to make scrapbooks of
their newspaper readings like like these
kinds of scrapbooks
for example had a number of options they
could buy blank books made specially
made for the purpose such as these and
mostly these were expensive album size
books they're okay for pictures but
they're not very book liked and they
don't and they're really too wide for
the bookshelf other people did buy bit
blank books that were more suitable for
newspaper columns but many of the
thousands of people who made scrapbooks
in the in the nineteenth century did not
buy blank books for the purpose and I
want to consider some of what that
they're not buying allowed them to do
and what they drew from their choices so
one important reading reason for reusing
books was cheapness of course an
availability many books had a single use
and then they were used up copy books
for practicing handwriting for example
like this one Clara Barton kept this
scrapbook as when she was a teacher so
you can see it's about a handwriting
practice page showing through on one
side and some made even used old
newspapers to make those scrapbooks
pasting them on top of old newspapers
but and many people used old business
letters that was very common after all
what use was the business ledger after
the business transacted recorded in it
was done or the business went out of
business so old or unwanted printed
books however also could be cheaper free
but using them raised stickier issues
the same way Lauren Conrad's work did no
one worried about pasting over old
ledges Ledger's or copy books but
pasting clippings over printed pages
made people very uneasy people Reeboks
reused this way included absolute
obsolete text books novels books of
sermons and even Bibles
in 1873 writer julia coleman reported
her distress at seeing a mother disc
directing her children to cut up books
she's visiting she finds the mother and
children all making scrapbooks each
child had a brush a pair of scissors
some waste paper and a book in the
latter one child was neatly pasting the
slips which he received from the mother
the narrator is shocked why you were
using good printed books good for that
was the Yankees reply more easily made
than gang said there is nothing in them
that we want and so we propose putting
in something rather than have them stand
idle Hubert's you see is an old day book
and we have one or two others some of
them are schoolbooks not much worn but
out-of-date almost every library has
some useless books the mother explains
that buying blank scrapbooks would be
too expensive since each child has at
least two scrapbooks to accommodate
interests and Julia Coleman is one over
for some of the reasons Coleman was
uneasy about reuse many people prized
the visual and tactile qualities of the
bound printed book as well as its
prestige reusing books this way meant
that scrapbook making was truly a
democratic practice it required very
little money to create a substantial and
authoritative book that privileged ones
on reading interests and tastes so who
made these graphics well and and what
were they made for it wasn't just
children and let me give you a little
background in writing with scissors very
simple I investigated what ordinary 19th
century readers newspaper readers did
with their reading now unlike anyone you
know but they felt there was just too
much to read in their lives and they
felt overwhelmed by it so newspapers had
become cheap but the material in them
seemed tantalizingly valuable if only it
could be saved so it could be accessible
again you could have piles of papers in
your house but they were unindexed and
you'd never find anything so the
forward-looking household made
scrapbooks ten
thousands people of people did this
statesmen such as Abraham Lincoln did it
Frederick Douglass as well and Charles
Sumner and actors such as Sarah
Bernhardt writers such as Horatio Alger
Jack London and Mark Twain there's a
cartoon of him with his self pasting
scrapbook which he invented and tell you
about a little later
so I've read hundreds of these
scrapbooks over the past 10 years and
it's a fascinating realm of of writing
that of that's really just barely been
explored during the Civil War which is
kind of a watershed moment for scrapbook
making northerners and southerners made
scrapbooks that shape their sense of
nation as they experienced it through
the press poetry as well as its news
accounts the scrapbooks also reflect the
material conditions so northern
scrapbooks are abundant with printed
matter on Confederate scrapbooks have
faded ink more scattered access to
papers paper shortages in the south
since there wasn't that much
manufacturing and those scrap those
shortages affected their scrapbook
making one Confederate woman whose
scrapbook covers over a family grocery
ledger ran out of space but when she got
to the end of the ledger and goes back
and pastes things over the earlier come
newspaper columns so four hundred pages
weren't enough and so that you can read
the conditions the material conditions
of how people were making scrapbooks
what was it but they had access to
through the books they left behind with
lots of different kinds of people made
scrapbooks women's rights activists
collected concentrated and critiqued the
press that was covering their activities
through making their scrapbooks and
bridge their public and domestic
concerns sorry susan b anthony
scrapbooks or go on for if there was
about thirteen volumes of them and
they're pasted into old ledgers and she
thanks the businessman of rochester for
giving her these old Ledger's whether
that meant that they threw them out and
she got them or whether they really did
give them to her I don't know but she
does thank them
you can see the little columns of
figures sticking out behind so again
that maturing materials and the
scrapbookers of material of reports for
history in the women's rights movement
other suffragists did the same in the
years after emancipation
african-americans made massive
collections of scrapbooks saving items
about black people to compile what one
black journalist called hidden histories
often repurposing government reports for
their and other ones for their
scrapbooks and other scrapbooks are more
miscellaneous and idiosyncratic um so
what when these thousands of scrap book
makers covered over pages of existing
books they were destroying books in one
sense but that was to take advantage of
the prestige of the book as well as the
blank pages they displace the contents
whether schoolbooks or sermons um with
what they cared about poems or household
hints Patent Office reports were a
particular favorite agricultural reports
um because they were bulky they were
impressive looking and they became
arrived free from your congressman man
of course they were good and they were
particularly good as you can see for
holding two columns of newspaper I've
given you here you can see where
somebody stops pasting so you can see
the underlying page beneath there's that
one of the books that recommend
discusses how to keep scrapbooks
scrapbooks and how to make them by e/w
girly-girly explains that that these are
particularly good for keeping scrapbooks
because of the two columns and you get
them free and all of that and the
wonderful spyhole of the internet lets
us find him
actually in correspondence with the
North Carolina Agricultural Bureau
requesting agricultural reports he says
I cannot run the ran the farm without
them well you can see what he was really
doing with them so what was the content
of these scrapbooks these that they
covered the reports over with well or
I'm sorry that they covered over
tomorrow
as the the agricultural reports
Margaret Lin wrote a memoir about her
scrapbook keeping back in the about the
1870 1870s girlhood in Missouri and
she's very specific about her quarrel
with this the underlying contents of
books like this that she reused she
complains that the contents of the
agricultural reports were disappointing
they to her as a reader and that's
there's a typical one
yeah they had pictures and you can see
that's a pig heart but pictures of worms
bugs and hens mere hens standing up to
have their pictures taken no surprise
that she preferred to paste them over
with poetry that's not her scrapbook but
that's another one and stories from the
newspapers and she later became an
English professor so for Margaret land
repurposing the agricultural reports was
certainly a mode of critique she didn't
like what was there he pasted it over
but for other scrapbook makers who left
no narration of what their intent was we
can look for evidence within the book
itself now I started this project when I
was in a used bookstore in Massachusetts
the book the the bitch doorkeeper agreed
that I was interested in scrapbooks I
was looking at some other kind of
scrapbook the time and he can't be a
copy of a book of Puritan sermons look
at certain sermons what I'm going to do
with this I opened it up it was Baxter
Saints rest popular in the in the early
19th century it was widely reprinted as
a tract but when I open it up I
discovered inside and had been covered
over and the story that you can see
there barely see there is the revolt of
mother by Mary Wilkins Freeman does
anyone know that story okay so in that a
farm woman who has lived in a really
crummy house for forty to forty years of
her marriage married life her husband
goes off to buy new cows she moves the
family into the new barn that he's
because it's much more commodious and
beautiful in the house they've been
living in for all those years so
essentially this scrapbook maker did the
same thing she moved her
scrappy newspaper clippings into a much
more beautiful housing for them and so
she created a book that spoke to her
needs and it's interesting too that this
the farm woman who made this the
previous generation that had owned it
and there was an inscription in the
front of this scrapbook where somebody
inscribed the book of sermons through
her sister in the 1840s and then in the
1880s here it was taken over by a later
generation who clearly at the very least
didn't think much of the Puritan sermons
maybe she thought you know maybe she
hadn't even more pointed critique but we
can't really see that from from the book
itself we just know that she didn't
value what was underlying it now
girly EE girlies book on scrapbook
making recommends cutting out every
other page of the book that you're
pasting into so that you don't bulk up
the book too much so the clapping the
clippings don't don't make it over full
and this farm woman did that she took
good care of the new home that she put
her clippings in um she also saved a
clipping on the care of books
interestingly hints for using books
probably and it's where she says you
know don't hold the book too close to
the fire don't don't mark on it don't do
this and that and now it seems a wildly
paradoxical in in the context of a book
that's essentially destroyed a book but
on the other hand it speaks to the value
she attached to it to the sense of of
its importance as a book the heft the
gravitas and the sheer book nests of
this book that she reused so
generational arguments and possible
critiques appear in other form covering
over might indicate an attempt to ignore
the past or even hide it
a southern scrap white child in in
Carolina took an old family ledger from
the 1830s to 50s which enumerated slaves
if you could see that better you could
see that and in the 18 in the nineteen
teens and twenties he probably pasted
pictures of baseball players and film
stars film ads next to these pages
naming and giving prices for the
enslaved people who created his family's
wealth some of the clippings made and
Sully's clippings of course may also
cover over some of those those
enumerations now when they handed this
book this ledger to that child when the
older people of the family gave over
that ledger did they choose to cover
over the plantation past did they not
know what was there we don't know um but
another white southerner Sally Robertson
of Caswell Carswell North Carolina was
more deliberate she lost her brother in
the Civil War and was in her mid 40s in
the 1870s when she made her scrapbook
from a family ledger also drugstore
business in this case she seems to have
been had more thoroughly covered over
the family's slave of holding history
then pages that simply enumerated other
things about the business and she
covered them over with recipes and
advice many of them drawn from northern
papers so again a sense of covering over
dispute with the past what to do with it
and spoken through the reuse of books it
seems deliberate so what these newspaper
clippings look like clipping scrapbooks
look like well Robyn Bernstein has
introduced the idea into print culture
studies that a book scripts certain act
actions write her focus on is on reading
but we can use that idea in thinking
about how about scrapbook making as well
the size of the agricultural reports
page that so many reports the page that
so many scrapbook makers used which held
two newspaper columns so well scripted
covering over
the text portion of the page and so
ending up with a more book like page
making scrapbooks in the 19th centuries
allowed readers to shift ephemeral
clippings into these more permanent
repositories substantial book like
impressive on the Shelf there might even
be many shelves of these square of these
scrapbooks and african-american janitor
in Philadelphia
Joseph WH Cathcart made a hundred and
fifty scrapbooks and they're quite
massive about that big they're big and
bulky they're made out of government
reports which he densely pasted over so
you can barely tell anything about
what's underneath every once in a while
something keeps through and then he had
them rebound so you can just barely make
it out it says assassination of Lincoln
on trial and execution of the
conspirators but then at the bottom it
says the great by the great scrapbook
maker wjwh Cathcart um so he took great
obviously took great pride in his
productions but also the fact that it
was beautiful it was bound this way that
it was a substantial book reflected and
refracted prestige and it looked really
great on the bookshelf news he worked in
an office building and that meant that
newspaper reporters sometimes visited
him and because it was accessible
through them and they were very
impressed by seeing their ephemeral
clippings instead of wrapping fish were
pasted so nicely into these books and
one of them calculated how many volumes
they would fill if they were in regular
book type the prestige of the bound
books reflected on him and it reflected
on his project since he was a black man
in the not very distinguished job of
janitor he in all his accomplishment
would have been invisible to her the
reporter otherwise and it allowed
reporters to pay attention to the
content of his scrapbooks which they
also wrote about and the content was
very to a great extent black history and
that allowed them to write about it in
the
white newspaper or problem prompted them
to do it so newspaper clipping
scrapbooks were both book-like and
newspaper like and to some extent
they're like ideal newspapers within the
book they imitated the visual form of
the newspaper a magazine you can see
here and column after column placing
script news clippings in the form of the
recreated magazine or newspaper asserted
that they had a kind of order and logic
even if that's not always so obvious
miscellany columns in newspapers
sometimes in enhanced this sense by of
mirroring the newspaper as they reminded
readers that their contents were
suitable for scrapbooks so this is
feeding feedback loop their scrapbooks
could thus own their both the item and
the medium they replicated with it
repurposing Ledger's notebook date books
and many sorts of printed mat books
aloud scrapbook makers to create books
cheaply using substantial well bound
printed books let the materiality of the
text speak for and enhance its value
like Lauren Conrad with her exacto knife
and glue gun
19th century scrapbook makers created
works that looked great on the Shelf but
their creations preserve the clippings
that mattered to them they celebrated
their own reading tastes and interests
and they left us a record of their
reading
just a treat to be part of us so
delighted delighted to be here and to
come after these two fabulous papers so
I'm talking today from the cusp of two
different projects one's a project on
the relationship between childhood
studies and history an exploration of
the many different uses an exploration
of the ways that thinking about
childhood is thinking about the past the
other explores the many different uses
people make of manuscript books in the
mid 19th century for the last few years
I have largely experienced these as
competing projects research and writing
tasks that conveniently distract me from
each other but the object I'd like to
talk about today reflects on both of
these projects and so stumbling upon at
this summer is proving helpful to me for
thinking about the relationship between
them I'm anchoring this talk in a single
homemade book the writing preserved in
this book centers on family ties and
hence the book proves fruit a fruitful
place for thinking about the roles books
play in family life and in particular in
structuring the relations between
parents and children my project on what
this panel calls handmade books studies
mid 19th century American that are a
production that was generally not
intended for publication it asks what
these practices of manuscript bookmaking
can teach us about reading authorship
and the roles literature may play both
in national formations and an individual
lives the rapid changes in the literary
marketplace that began in the late 1820s
reflected and spurred an altered
relation to print culture was a widening
generic variety of cheaper more easily
available books fostering a different
kind of intimacy not only with printed
things but with the basic form of the
book booksellers regularly sold an array
of blank books alongside printed texts
and it's clear that there was a general
market conception that people interested
in buying books to read would also be
interested
filling books themselves many of these
volumes were explicitly structured for
quite specific uses often however users
were far more fluid in their treatment
of these volumes so that for example add
a ledger of household expenses might
come to be used as a commonplace book
and as Elin Garvey has just shown even
books filled with print were often
repurposed by scrap work so it's not
surprising that blank books would be
particularly prone to being repurposed I
want to suggest that these practices
indicate the porosity between the roles
of reader and author during this period
and can be seen as instancing a
democratizing and authorizing effect of
print culture that exceeds print itself
the particular book I'll talk about
today repurposes a book intended for
institutional records to hold effective
relations the ties between parents and
children I'm also going to reference
Robert Bernstein's wonderful term of the
scripted thing because books are
powerfully scripted things they enter
our hands accompanied by a presumed
script for their use the school primer
the large family Bible and a small
pocket one the ornately bound novel part
of a set and the paper cover adventure
The Dictionary the philosophical essay
the collection of sonnets if they all
script read me what they mean by that
act is widely different in audience
setting and manner we know too that they
invite other non reading uses as
cultural capital to decorate library
shelves or parlor table and as physical
object to raise a seat or crop open a
door Bernstein's concept of the script
insists both on the compelling power of
social and material expectation and on
the ever possible alternatives of
individual performance the capacity to
use scripted things in some other
unscripted or less scripted way the
volume I'll take as my example today is
very explicitly labeled to announce its
intended purpose the word records
stamped in gold on its spine
Marielle bacon does use this book for
records in it she records events and
relationships of deep importance to her
but not quite in the scripted way the
stamp suggests a sticker inside the back
cover reveals that the book was
purchased from Sage and brothers a
bookseller in Rochester New York this
1840 advertisement for the firm proves
useful for thinking about this
particular volume but it also helped
Felice encapsulates the porosity of the
book trade as a whole the mix of sage
and brothers literary wares include a
large and well selected assortment of
American and foreign school classical
theological law and miscellaneous books
touted together with blank books of
every description I don't know how well
you can read a list I'm quoting things
from that ad printing and binding work
including the valuable possession of the
stereotype plates for Sanders spelling
book and a specific note on the Sabbath
School depository such a miscellany is
quite characteristic of the period with
advertisements for booksellers varying
frequently including mentions of blank
books among their wares the efforts of
booksellers to create distinct blank
books for disparate purposes clearly
aims to increase sales and many blank
books are highly distinctive with a
great deal of internal apparatus
intended to structure specific business
or domestic uses but more like this one
truly are blank the stamped records may
suggest business and organizational uses
but the lightly line but otherwise
unmarked pages inside do not preclude
other sorts of records Marielle bacon
use this book to record grief as a tool
of family life and specifically of
mourning the most comprehensive and
insightful study of such practices is
Mary Lewis Keats Louise Keats
sentimental collaborations Mary Bacon's
appropriation of this book as a vehicle
of mourning appears to be rather
different more gradual and haphazard
less clear and purposive than that key
finds in the blank book Lois Gould gave
to her new sister-in-law in
scribing within the opening pages of
Harriet Gould book a clear directive
that seemed to have as keeps writes a
specific use for the volume in mind
should dearest friends some kind momento
trace along the unwritten columns of
this book when distance or the grave
hides form and face into this volume
sweet will be to look each fond
remembrance oft will speak to you in
language which may never be forgot of
those who ever constant were and true
and gently whisper oh forget me not my
discussion of this manuscript book
follows in many ways on Keats analysis
of Harriet Gold's book but with
attention lest to collaboration and more
to that act of recording and to the uses
of books evidenced by this less
intentional more randomly structured
volume Mary Bacon's repurposing of this
records book is moreover hybrid in its
combination of the commonplace book
aesthetics that Rachel describes and the
friendship the scissoring practices of a
scrapbook maker that Ellen Garvey
describes and the friendship album or
keepsake book model of Harriet gules
book thus one striking characteristic of
this little volume is that it
demonstrates the makers awareness of a
wide range of ways of using blank books
and draws upon them all as the prior
papers suggest the move from commonplace
book to scrapbook is it once a medium
and a temple shift and Mary Bacon's
records book reflects this shift with
her own writing and copying dominating
her use of this volume in the 1840s and
newspaper clippings taking over in the
1860s that is that civil war watershed
that that Ellen was talking about used
sporadically over a period of 20 years
the elasticity of form reflects and
reflects such shifts in print culture as
well as the elasticity of grief itself
it seems likely that this volume is
indeed acquired by the bacons for the
more institutional record-keeping
purposes the sage brothers presume their
customers
want miscellaneous books being the only
category of books if you can call it
that mentioned in their circular not
aimed at a pedagogical professional or
institutional market the needs of the
Reverend Charles L bacon a pastor in the
Baptist Church and a leading figure in
the organizational work of the Seneca
Baptist Association are well reflected
in this list of wares and in the records
title of this book but if he did
purchase this blank book with Church or
Association records in mind he didn't
use it that way all the writing and
pasting in this book was done by his
wife Mary Reverend Charles Bacon's
understanding of the role that books
play in family life is adamantly
expressed in one of the many circular
letters he wrote for the seneca Baptist
Association books of a character to
refine enlighten and expand the mind
should be found in the library it is the
most sad and palpable dereliction of
duty on the part of Christian parents
that they do not provide their families
with such books as are appropriate to
Sabbath reading pride is gratified and
rests and equip egde while the shelves
of the family library are either
entirely empty or what is worth filled
with the light dissipating literature of
the day he writes sets dismay over the
literary derelictions of christian
parents insist on the moral force of
literature and family life and on the
preeminent responsibility of parents for
ensuring that neither the shelves of
their libraries nor the souls of their
children are frivolous and empty on
parents alone he insists rests the duty
and responsibility of the moral and
religious culture of their children the
assumptions about books and family life
at stake in these pronouncements clearly
conformed to Mary's use of this book to
record family ties that vision of the
family library's empty shelves does
haunt moreover since the pages of this
records book are mostly empty Mary
appears to have used the book at least
four separate memorial responses to
familial sorrows after the death of her
father in 1840 of her daughter in 1847
of her mother in 1850
and finally rather differently as a
scrapbook reflective of the family's
joys and trials in the early 1860s upon
opening the volume it seems likely to be
very full since the first blank page
here we go
facing the front cover a space most
users of blank books leave blank or
reserved for some brief gesture of title
or inscription appears to be the
beginning of a scrapbook here Mary
neatly pasted in and labeled two
newspaper poems published in the
Truman's burg news in 1861 this bit of
1861 scrap work is followed in the book
by many blank pages more than half and
though that first entry in the book is
viewed front to back it is clearly not
Mary's first use of the volume the
earliest dated item in this book is a
short obituary clipping for her father
from the New York Baptist Register which
Mary sewed not pasted into the book
inserting the label I don't know if you
can see it but you can totally see the
stitches inserting the label January
1840 since the clipping itself does not
provide a month or a year I'll read it
to you on the 10th alt alia who Baker in
the 76th year of his age after a long
residence at Hamilton in this state he
emigrated early in September last to
Medina Michigan the residents of his
son-in-law
Reverend CS the print s adamantly
corrected in pen to L bacon where he
died he was a man of most exemplary
deportment and esteem and all the
relations of life his death was like his
life peaceful and full of Christian hope
Mary's addendum and corrections
demonstrate the limits of the newspaper
obituary as itself a record of her
father's death since its own local
periodical ephemeral qualities means
that its references to time and place
alt this state cannot be trusted to
preserve crucial information even though
the very fact of this obituaries speaks
to the ways in which allele bakers
Hamilton New York community sought to
use the paper to compensate for the
separations caused by his own late life
emigration to live with his daughter
above it she sewed a lock of his hair
now gone the spring is clipped and this
page too has been clipped cut out of the
book and stored loose between the blank
pages near the end the reason for this
renewal is clear the edges of the cut
pages are visible in the center of the
volume the page the left copies out the
obituary in Mary's hand naming the
source and quietly correcting the
confusing omission of month and year and
that wrong middle initial a lock of
still quite brown hair is sown above my
father's hair precious indeed penned in
an arc above the curve evidently Mary
cut the right hand page from the book
sometime after 1850 in order to make an
obituary page for her mother to match
and face the one that she had made for
her father who had died a decade earlier
in doing so she privileges the
manuscript copying out of the newspaper
notice over the inclusion of a paper
clipping and indeed the records book
holds no actual newspaper clipping of
her mother's far longer more personal
obituary Mary decorates the page with
its own now largely disintegrated gray
curl of my mother's hair precious relic
a phrase that echoes the language of the
obituary which describes mrs. Polly
Baker as a relic of a lucu alejo Baker
and at the top of the page she pins a
newspaper funeral announcement for a
friend below her father's obituary she
writes two poems one for each parent
secreted in the middle pages of this
volume and I love Rachael's notion of
the hidden book so this feels very much
like hidden books these records of Greek
appear less as communal sentimental
collaborations in Keats terms then as a
personal effort to honor these losses in
a way that draws on print on writing on
relic to create symmetrical memorials to
her to parents and to place them once
or side by side with in her book the
symmetrical verses to her father's name
and mother's voice are in fact not just
symmetrical but actually two stanzas of
the same poem that had first been
published in the fall
following Mary's mother's death in
copying these stanzas into her record
book Mary changes the gendering of the
first stanza so that this voice of the
motherless could express the loss of a
father the table of contents of the
Baptist monthly and memorial record
credits the poem to mrs. L Baxter and it
would later be included in Baxter's 1855
collection gems by the wayside but when
Mary copies it into her book she copies
the erroneous credit from the Baptist
monthly MLB her own initials and truly
she is made these stands as her own as
two separate and differently gendered
poems that celebrate the tender comfort
and guidance provided by both her
parents Mary includes two poems to her
mother and father in a similar
symmetrical array on the next page of
this book the one to her father does to
the best of my knowledge appear to be
her own composition the one to her
mother is a well-known song by Samuel
lover a staple of nineteenth-century
anthologies magazines song sheets and
hymnals both poems are structured by
recollection a longing for the past I
miss I pine and a position of dependency
and nurture that I remember well that
place of childhood the active
inscription the creation of these
memorial records casts Mary herself of
course in the role of caretaker even as
what she preserves as the childhood role
of being cared for her father's obituary
itself explains that Mary's parents
moved to Michigan precisely so she could
fill this caretaking role for them part
of what I wish to demonstrate with this
records book are the ways in which Mary
understands the book itself as a space
in which to construct reconstruct the
family that feels to her in other ways
and places painfully precarious the
sentimental promise of such poetry is of
course heavenly reunion in the last two
lines of
for her father Reid though I on earth no
father have yet unto me is given the
hope they firm anchor of my soul that I
have to in heaven but this is a solace
that she construct in the mirroring
arrangements of these pages Charles and
Mary bacon moved back to New York State
in 1845 settling in a series of smaller
towns outside Rochester where Charles
served as pastor well it's possible if
the records book was brought to Michigan
by the bakers or purchased in some
earlier trip back to New York it seems
most likely that this book was procured
after 1845 Mary used it most extensively
to record the death of her daughter Sara
who died after a short illness on
February 9th 1847 that is in the years
between the deaths of Mary's father and
mother the records of grief Mary
produces for her daughter Phil a more
extended segment of the book than the
two memorial spreads the two-page
memorial spread Mary made for her
parents and it draws upon a wider array
of genres and writing practices copying
newspaper obituaries and poetry again
locks of hair but also some pages of
personal narrative that she titles
incidents in the life of my little
daughter these writings - secreted near
the end of the volume do not seem
intended for show
there are many blank pages to leaf
through to find them and while they do
include poems Mary labels as words of
comfort sent to her by friends and hence
evidence of the sorts of collaborative
communities of mourning Keats describes
they are all copied into this book by
Mary's hand who records as well their
source here for example a poem Mary
herself wrote on the fourth anniversary
of my daughter Sarah's burial and one
cent to be by mrs. David a Miller after
the death of my dear daughter
Charles bacon also writes a poem that
Mary copies into the book and festoons
this page with curls from her two
daughters
Charles has written this poem as if in
Sarah's voice and in it she instructs
her mother both to undertake such
memorializing gestures and not to cry
over them Oh mother dear we
not for me think little Sara's passed
away where flowers bloom air to decay
weep not for me my little lock of
shining hair dear mother keep with
tender care but or it never shed a tear
oh not for me instructions it's hard to
imagine either parent could fully follow
as in the way Mary arranged her parents
memorial pages to configure within this
book her parents marriage in her own
position as beloved and protected child
this page explicitly works to recreate
her marital family
Charles words in Sarah's voice written
with Mary's hand and the hair of both
their children the hair is labeled in
block letters Allie P beacon and Sarah L
bacon the only such writing in this book
and surely done so that seven-year-old
Allie might be able to recognize her
name and understand something of her
sister's death this page truly is a
collaboration when explicitly about
family belonging the role of teacher
that Sarah occupies in this poem
characterizes her role throughout the
prose memoir which in choosing incidents
in the life of my little daughter to
transcribe focuses on in son scenes of
instruction
Sarah's final death is certainly like
that marked by initial fear and
resistance but closing with that secure
and blessed welcoming of death that is
the urine for denouement of all death
bed narratives of the period let me go
to heaven lay me back in the settee and
let me go but the rest of the incidents
recorded while still powerfully
sentimental are far more idiosyncratic
and at least for a 21st century reader
more moving after her paw had risen in
the morning she would invariably come
and get into bed with me and she would
then say mom raise up your head just a
minute
and she would put one arm under my neck
and the other over and then say now ma
let's say the president's in order and
she would then repeat them regularly as
she had learned them in school and she
would then say now ma you say them and I
would
miss awkwardly as possible putting the
first last and the last first just to
see what she would say Oh Massey Wales
you don't say them right but it ain't
any matter you know cuz I can tell you
just as well you need not feel bad MA
and I would then repeat them correctly
and she would break out in ecstasy
that's right MA
that's right I knew you could say them
Mary's a wonderful storyteller here and
a very self-conscious one carefully
inscribing a lisping dialect of
childhood dis minute lists a and the
dynamics of the family in which of the
child teaches she does so because the
mother has pretended deficiencies for
the pleasure of being corrected the
daughter's faith in her mother's
capacity to learn the generosity of her
childish pedagogy provides a powerful
demonstration of the mother's own good
teaching not just of the names of
presidents but of patience and
generosity with deficiencies this book
itself is all out of order full of gaps
and discontinuities literally putting
the first last and the last first many
clippings mostly of mourning and
religious poetry are preserved loose
between the pages a collection begun but
never pasted down into any kind of order
there are a few more disparate clippings
one on modes of preparing the peach
pickled peaches peach prunes peach jam
peach jelly peach wine and another poem
the idiot boy surprised me for its
difference from Wordsworth's poem of
that name not knowing that this panel
was going to start with another
Wordsworth but also because it's subject
matters suddenly put into relief a few
lines in Mary's narrative that I had
wondered over our situation as a family
two little daughters one unfortunate
helpless and perfectly dependent the
other bright healthy and exceedingly
promising and another line he was
extremely fond of her little sister who
was unfortunate or she termed her my
dear sick sister for Mary whose bright
healthy and exceedingly promising
daughter had died
18:47 the comfort of this poems elegy
must have been complex indeed sweeter
fair ones were left her winsome full of
joy but how sweeter the dependence of
that idiot boy the entries for the Bacon
household in the 1850 and 1860 census
and the column for those whether deaf
and dumb blind and saying idiotic pauper
or convict clearly marks Alice as
idiotic this poem was printed in 1861
the same year that Louis Halsey gave
Alice a canary and published two poems
for Alice and the Truman's burg news
Mary's returned to this book in 1861
apparently not having written anything
in it for a decade her last entry seems
to be the poem marking the fourth
anniversary of Sarah's burial with these
scraps she remakes the book into a
celebration of the daughter she has left
letting the resilience of the handmade
book express the resilience of this
family
and we went
surprise
great but
creation it's the Knicks I mean some of
the if I had chosen different slides
you'd see did something different but I
would say that most of the newspaper
clipping scrapbooks I looked at did not
have handwritten materials in them I've
seen commonplace books that morph into
clipping scrapbooks and sort of
something the way that you're talking
Karen was talking about the one that I
didn't look at didn't talk about was it
the two slides that I skipped the Edward
Newfield you knew something or other
Taylor it was a diary that he kept from
any a businessman New York businessman
kept for many years and during the Civil
War it sort of bul versions you know it
bloats up because he can't keep up with
things writing about them and he just
starts flipping in and clipping the
newspaper and stuffing that in as well
so that's not a commonplace but but a
diary where the clippings take over but
you do see that in common close books to
where as newspaper gets cheap there just
seems to be too much to keep up with
that that starts taking over the book in
that way so that's different from
marginalia that's what's going in the
other direction there is also some
margin Eliot in the scrapbooks but I
think that Bernstein's point about
scripting the double columns if you're
doing if you're pasting over a book and
you're covering over the printed text
block with the columns of newsprint
you're not really leaving yourself much
room to write sometimes people annotate
with you know dates and so forth but and
there are more particular uses of
annotation that I go into in the book
but but it does seem to have being art
in some ways an artifact of the of the
remade you know agricultural reports or
novel or whatever it is if you've
already got the space all crammed with
text of various sorts it's a printed
text it's harder to squeeze in your
but I think it's both I mean it's not so
much lacking the possibility but I mean
the idea of scripting I think is useful
for that because it's it's sort of oh
why would you let me it's for complete
in itself it's not I mean except that
you do end up seeing sometimes these
little notes that's say somebody esra a
morning I'm thinking of one scrapbook
that has a a mourning poem in it and
somebody writes next to it the name of
someone not mentioned in the poem it's
that you know three attributes
reattaches that grief to someone that
they know so you do see these little
scattered notes on them it was very
interesting to me when she first showed
her father's news clip obituary which
you know had problems with it because it
had the wrong initials or whatever but
when she decided she wanted to make
those pages face each other she could
have decided the other thing right she
could have decided to keep the newsprint
and putting in news nothing for her
mother and she said like just forget
this I'm going all handwriting even
though what she did was copy out the
obituary so there's mhm you know there
seems like there was some moment there
where she truly like had those
alternatives in front of her and you
know chose one as better caring what she
wanted I think there's also the act of
writing that that's yeah also our
physical quality of inscribing becomes
important in some that
yes it would so that when I was talking
about floating island at hawks head so
the question was to talk more about
interpretations of floating island at
hawks head my interpretations other
interpretations what happens when the
poem lives and to print and so and this
the story of this project it's kind of
in the anecdote that it's my reading of
this poem because I am at a moment of
transition from a first to a second
project and my first project is very
different it's about debates about
infinity among mathematicians and
philosophers and the ways in which
Romantic period poetry and aesthetics
could have come out of these debates
about infinity and so my reading of
floating island at hawks head which is
what sort of led me to the archives in
the in the first place was you know my
desire to make this reading in context
of the daily writings I'm is that the
poem represents Dorothy words response
to William Wordsworth upon habitat so
upon epitaph there's a moment in the FA
upon epitaph
the first one I'm where there's a child
and the child is watching a stream flow
and then it flows into this ocean that's
a symbol on a map and it's the real
object in nature and it's this
abstraction and it's eternity right it's
the afterlife and there's sort of room
for the soul and eternity and so by
counting right by watching the stream
flow and realizing it could flow forever
and then realizing that there is an
ocean at this child and Wordsworth si
realizes that there must be an afterlife
right and so that sort of Wordsworth
riffing on Locke's definition of
identity in terms of infinity which is
very influential in the Romantic period
and basically Locke just says right we
count we realize we could always add one
so we kind of believe in infinity
positive idea of it and then by that
logic we count the moments that we are
ourselves and we could always be
ourselves for one more moment so we
could always be ourselves forever so
that's how we have a cohesive idea of
identity
and in William Wordsworth sort of
romantic interpretation of that is to
say and that's how we believe in sort of
the Eternity of our identity right so
you can I won't i won't really do this
home again right but you'll remember
that there's um as opposed to a stream
flowing right there's something sort of
very mortal dissolving but somehow
remaining right so Dorothy Henry stages
and that scene it's really interesting
the part about print coming back to the
previous question about script in print
one flat poem moves into print it's
printed in a collection of William Wirt
source poetry and it's printed right
after this poem by Sarah Hutchinson so
William Wordsworth
sister-in-law who had passed away and
she had written this poem to a red
breath straight where she says my red
breaths you know
don't fail to be the harbinger of
everlasting spring that's not a perfect
quote my Requiem sing or fail to be the
harbinger of everlasting spring that's
the quote great so it's this sort of
duck bed poem to nature asking the Red
Robin way to be her harbinger of spring
that's not the literal spring of the
natural world with the eternal spring of
the afterlife and then if you look at
the at the copies as the poem moved into
print right Mary Wordsworth ghost doing
kind of exaggerated it's her sister's
swan song right and adds all these Oh
exclamation point right that kind of
thing and then they publish it and then
on the next page you got I'm floating
out at hawks head and after and it's
just called floating islands and then
after the title it tells you to remember
the previous poem right so remember SHS
poem while you're reading DW poem and
then at the bottom it's on two pages and
at the bottom of that page there's a
little poem by Wordsworth where he sort
of talks about the moon and the star
right and how these sort of the there
are these two luminous body is right the
female poets the two poems that are
published anonymously but labeled as
feminine so so interestingly when
floating islands can move
Despres it becomes an allergy and it
becomes a female allergy in this really
scripted way and it also becomes write a
conversation poem it becomes a poem
that's sort of paired with this other
poem and they're published as in
conversation and then Wordsworth
comments on them in verse so I think
those were the two points I wanted that
spot you've probably had enough of the
books that they were created and then
where have you found some of them
store are they when you kinda play I
guess I'll start then Carla asked among
other things first public and private
the relation Republican private in the
scrapbook how how did the creators of
scrapbooks of or the other works that
we've been hearing about think about how
their works would endure do they have a
sense of an audience do they have a
sense of creating for an audience is
that accurate and also when we find them
in the archives how are they labeled
what are we seeing what are we what how
do we find them for one thing is that
I'm not quite flushing that one out okay
so let me start with the last first the
scrapbooks are very are very elusive
kinds of things but they're you
ubiquitous and elusive they are in
almost every repository of any sort but
they're often within family papers
they're not you know nobody says oh we
have a whole large collection of
scrapbooks that I'm sure you're gonna
want to see so one way I have found them
is whenever I travel anywhere I haven't
I would write to the wall the archives
in the area and write to the librarians
and archivists and say do you have
scrapbooks and I was looking for
particular kinds at that point at
various points and so the fact is that
you have to love your librarians and
archivists and rely on them and hope
them hope that they will help you
because they know what's buried in the
stacks very often these things are are
described in such various forms in the
catalogues that it's it's hard to locate
them so if you I mean even a very well
supportive institution that has the kind
of cataloging that indicate you know it
allows you to do a forms on research
online might miss quite a few but
there's some very smart librarian
hanging
in the archives who knows about the box
in the back and so there's that and
maybe other just want to comment on that
before we return to the question of
audience yeah I mean I would say my
manuscript book project has very
similarly with like Ellen everywhere I
am I did just go in and say oh and they
even have less of a genre than
specialists and kind of unsearchable in
that way there's not really I have not
found any good terms
hmm to put into search engines that will
then show me what's there so it really
is a question of sort of looking at
finding aids for family papers and
institutional papers and talking to
librarians who generally do know I've
been not working with Diaries which are
the most normal form of that so I just
there's just much more study of Diaries
as a form people have tried to think
about those days my history books I'm
trying to think about the ones that are
that and they take very different forms
from each other and really I think it's
meant for me that I'm not I'm not trying
to be comprehensive I don't think I have
anywhere near any kind of I'm just
trying to find ones that I find
interesting and then try to understand
what's going on inside of them
and in different ways that that people
are using these empty books to tell
stories that
they feel neat telling and that are not
stories that are that generally get into
print enough and I guess part of what I
found really moving about the big in
book is that what became for me the most
poignant story in it that is the story
of Alice is not a story that she's even
quite telling in it that there's no
place in the book it is and my daughter
Alice right so there's sort of like a
hidden book inside the book that is it's
it's most powerful piece of plot I
needed to find a census record to just
say oh yes I understand now that can I
just pick up on that that also speaks to
the importance of actually say looking
to knock bookstores or ebay but to
library collections where you actually
have some information on the person who
made it so that you could then work out
your the name of the person and then get
back over to the census records so I
mean otherwise if it's an anonymous work
without any of that possibility then you
can I'll just say quickly that question
was a good reminder that I didn't fight
my source for the manuscript since this
is going on the Internet
so that's story thing weird sort of
commonplace book and it's at the Jared
Center which is in Grasse Mayer and it
belongs to the Wordsworth trust and and
I'll just add my projects a little bit
different insofar as I am looking at
people that we read already that we read
a certain way and asking how reading the
material history but reading the
material history in a sort of trance
historical context of experimental
literature can help us write reread
people like Dorothy Wordsworth or
Michael field or write Lorraine edik are
all the different figures in this
project that I'm
putting together right how can we read
them differently so it's a similar
project but it comes from a different a
different starting point in terms of the
figures that are included